♪
>> GREG: AS THE CRAZY FALLOUT
KEEPS GETTING WORSE FOR NEW
YORK'S DISGRACED GOVERNOR HE
COULD NOW FACE CRIMINAL CHARGES,
MULTIPLE D.A.'S ARE LAUNCHING
PROBES.
CUOMO IS DEFIANT AS EVER DESPITE
MOUNTING PRESSURE FROM DEMOCRATS
TO STEP ASIDE.
>> I THINK HE SHOULD RESIGN.
I'M SURE THERE WERE SOME EMBRACE
THAT IS WERE TOTALLY INNOCENT
BUT APPARENTLY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS DECIDED THAT THERE
WERE THINGS THAT WEREN'T.
>> HE SHOULD RESIGN.
>> THE FACT THAT THERE ARE 11
WOMEN COMING FORWARD IS DEEPLY
DISTURBING.
>> GREG: WHAT ABOUT MIKE CUOMO?
HE IGNORED IT ON HIS SHOW.
CONFIDENTIAL STATE INTEL AND
HELPED TO WRITE A RESPONSE TO
ONE OF HIS BROTHERS' ACCUSERS.
YESTERDAY, GREG, YOU BROUGHT UP
RALPH NORTHHAM.
THE BLACK FACE SCANDAL AND
EVERYBODY CALLED ON HIM TO
RESIGN, EVEN DEMOCRATS.
HE DIDN'T DO IT AND NOW HE'S
STILL SITTING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
>> GREG: I THINK THIS IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE HE'S GOT THE
HARD LEFT AFTER HIM.
HE'S LIKE KING KONG RIGHT NOW AT
THE TOP OF THE BUILDING SWATTING
AT THE PLANE.
STILL CLUTCHING A WOMAN.
I DON'T THINK HE'S GOING TO
LAST.
BUT I GO BACK TO WHAT GERALDO
SAID.
WHO REPLACES HIM?
WE MIGHT BE GOING FROM THE OUTER
CIRCLE OF HELL TO THE INNER
CIRCLE OF HE WILL IF WE GET
JAMES OR deBLASIO.
HE'S GOT TO GO.
11 WOMEN, AND, I MEAN, WE SHOULD
JUST SIT BACK AND LET THE
PROCESS TAKE CARE OF IT.
CHRIS CUOMO IS JUST LUCKY, HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO EVER COVER BIG
UGLY STORIES.
HE CAN PLAY WITH A Q-TIP BUT HE
CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE NURSING
HOMES.
HE CAN TALK ABOUT HOW HIS BRO IS
READY TO MINGLE BUT HE CAN'T
TALK ABOUT THE CRIMES WITH
WOMEN.
IT'S ODDLY CONVENIENT.
CNN SHOULD HAVE HIM ON AS A
GUEST.
CNN SHOULD HAVE CHRIS CUOMO ON
AS A GUEST.
THEREFORE HE DOESN'T RUN THE
SEGMENT AND THEY COULD ASK HIM
QUESTIONS.
>> I SHOULD CREATE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST WITH REGARD TO JANUARY
6 SO I NEVER HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
IT.
I'M SORRY, I HAVE A CONFLICT.
CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT.
DANA PERINO, FROM A PUBLIC
RELATIONS STANDPOINT, CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE CHRIS -- PLEASE GIVE
GOVERNOR CUOMO A GRADE ON HOW
HE'S DONE THUS FAR?
>> DANA: I WOULD SAY F FOR
INTEGRITY BUT YOU'VE GOT TO SAY,
HE'S BASICALLY GOING TO HOLD ON.
HE'LL BE GODZILLA, KING KONG.
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY HE DRAGS
THIS THING OUT AS LONG AS HE
CAN.
HE DOESN'T CARE THAT HE DOESN'T
HAVE A FRIEND IN THE WORLD.
HE DOESN'T CARE -- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HE DID THAT'S SO
EGREGIOUS IS CHANGING THE RULES
SO THAT THAT STATE TROOPER THAT
HE HAD HIS EYES ON WOULD THEN BE
ADDED TO HIS DETAIL, AND THEN HE
HARASSED HER IN FRONT OF
EVERYBODY AND HER BOSS DID
NOTHING ABOUT IT WHILE HE WAS
DOING IT.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST
EGREGIOUS THINGS.
SHE'S ONE OF THE 11.
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO COME FORWARD
BUT SHE DID BECAUSE SHE THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
EVERYONE ELSE IS DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND HE'S DOING THE WRONG
THING.
HE DOESN'T CARE THAT HE DOESN'T
HAVE A FRIEND IN THE WORLD.
THE OTHER THING, NORTHHAM
APOLOGIZED AND THEN POWERED
THROUGH.
THIS GUY IS A COMPLETE JERK.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA,
WE KEEP SHOWING THE VIDEO HE PUT
OUT -- HE JUST KISSES EVERYBODY
AND EVERYTHING IS FINE.
LIKE NO BIG DEAL.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO ALTHOUGH MAYBE FROM
A P.R. PERSPECTIVE, MAYBE IT WAS
SMART.
THEY PUT OUT THIS VIDEO AND KEEP
PLAYING IT.
>> HE ALWAYS LOOKS LIKE HE'S
TRYING TO SUCK A PIMPLE.
>> GERALDO, IF THIS MOVES
FORWARD WITH IMPEACHMENT HOW
LONG WILL A PROCESS LIKE THAT
LAST?
>> IMPEACHMENT IS HIS BIG PERIL
BUT I HAVE TO SAY ANDREW CUOMO
IS NO HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE CHARGES.
SOMETHING AND DISGRACEFUL, YOU
KNOW, MAKES ME PUKE AND THIS
GUY -- YOU KNOW, HE DIDN'T RAPE
ANYBODY.
I MEAN, I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT -- IT'S INTERESTING TO ME
THAT EVERYONE HAS SEIZED ON
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND NOBODY
MENTIONS THE NURSING HOME.
NOBODY MENTIONS THESE HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHO DIED
ARGUABLY BECAUSE OF VANCOUVER
DECISIONS MADE IN ALBANY.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT IT.
THEY HAVE A PRESS CONFERENCE.
WE LOST 15,000 PEOPLE.
THEY GET TWO REPORTERS TO SHOW
UP.
SEXUAL ASSAULT, THEY GET 300
JUMPING ALL OVER EACH OTHER
ASKING, DID HE PUT HIS HAND ON
HER ELBOW?
DID HE SMOOTH HIS MUSTACHE -- HE
DOESN'T HAVE A MUSTACHE -- I
JUST THINK
>> IT IS A POINT THAT THIS
SCANDAL IS MORE DEVASTATING
POLITICALLY THAN THE OTHER
SCANDAL WHERE PEOPLE DIED AS A
RESULT.
>> DANA: AND HE HID DATA TO
COVER IT UP.
WITH THAT, PEOPLE WERE ENGAGED
TOGETHER.
THE NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR MADE
SOME OF THE SAME DECISIONS.
THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR IN
MICHIGAN MADE SOME OF THE SAME
DECISIONS.
SO THEY ALL KIND OF WANTED SOME
IMMUNITY FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WHICH APPARENTLY THEY
WERE HAPPY TO GIVE THEM BUT ON
THE RESIGNATION OF ANDREW CUOMO,
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'LL RESIGN.
I DON'T THINK HE WILL.
I THINK HE'LL STAY AND THIS IS
ALL UP TO THE DEMOCRATS TO HOLD
HIM ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY ARE IN CHARGE AND IF THEY
WANT TO PUT THEIR MONEY WHERE
THEIR MOUTH IS WHEN IT COMES TO
ME, TOO, HARASSMENT, THEY WOULD
IMPEACH HIM.
BIDEN SAID YESTERDAY HE SHOULD
RESIGN BUT WHEN THEY WERE
PRESSED AGAIN TODAY ABOUT
WHETHER HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE HE WON'T
RESIGN THEY WON'T GO AS FAR AS
SAYING DEMOCRATS SHOULD IMPEACH
HIM AND INTERESTING AND IRONIC,
BASED ON THE NURSING HOME ISSUE,
TODAY JEN WAS ASKED IF HE SHOULD
STILL BE IN A LEADERSHIP
POSITION ON THESE COVID CALLS
FOR ALL THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS
EVERY WEEK WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
AND SHE SAID THAT SHE DOESN'T
WANT TO HURT THE PEOPLE OF NEW
YORK BY REMOVING ANDREW CUOMO
FROM A POSITION OF LEADERSHIP TO
RUN THE COVID RESPONSE, BUT NOT
JUST FOR NEW YORK, BUT FOR THE
OTHER STATES AS IF HE HASN'T
DONE ALL OF THIS DAMAGE
INCLUDING PUTTING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE BACK INTO THE NURSING
HOMES.
SO THEY ARE KIND OF USING THAT
AS A SHIELD RATHER THAN TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR IT, AND IT'S
ONE THING TO SAY HE SHOULD
RESIGN BUT IT'S ANOTHER TO CALL
FOR ACTION IF HE REFUSES.